it's how I'm gonna be pre-recording so
just gonna count down going so you can
get it up alright so we are live and
we're going in three two all right and
we all laugh by the campfire the last
word with Lord Cognito and Ibaka sand
can't find kind of hot today we got a
special guest in the house and before I
even say anything name wise I'm gonna
send it right back to you sir for your
interest of all time so let's bring this
man in style the way you do it best
let's go yeah all right
welcome so the last word episode number
69 there's another glorious Friday we're
back in front of the campfire for some
more looters shooter discussion I'm
extremely honored about our special
guests so we gonna get right into it I
want to introduce a Lord whose
outstanding contributions to the gaming
community it's truly a sight to behold
not only is this Lord the epitome of
journalistic professionalism but is
easily one of the very best writers in
the game whether it be as Canada takes
on television pop culture and of course
everyone's favorite Luther shooter the
Destiny franchise introducing the
novelists of the Earthborn trilogy hero
killer and renowned videogame writer for
Forbes calm fellow original gambit fan
and come shadow Keith he's got this
pharaoh in the bag helmet matte black
with the shoulders black to match live
from ohio and kind enough to make his
debut into the realm of the last word
mommy
Lord Paul Tassie how you doing sir good
thanks for having me that was the best
intro I've ever heard have you here by
the campfire oh man it's been long
overdue bang really pleasure meeting you
at a guardian car now what G snacks
alright meaning you guys awesome man
great to have you brother so we've got a
lot to discuss in case you guys have
been living under a rock which I know
you haven't but obviously anybody out
there listening we've got director's cut
part 1 director's cut part 2 Armour 2.0
stream so we have a lot to get through
today
and to respect mr. testes time we are
gonna try and keep this thing kind of
moving for it as best as possible but as
always you guys know we turn this into
long points sometimes so tangents are
possible but to get going I didn't want
to kind of if you just want to briefly
tell the audience if they don't know who
you are which I would be floored if they
don't but if they don't tell them tell
me who you are real quick just kind of
how long how long have you been writing
I caught it I was listen to DCP like a
year ago fir forsaken I think when you
were on there so it's kind of curious
what's changed since then so how long
have you been writing and then just how
long have like how many articles do you
think you're up to for destiny man I've
been writing for Forbes specifically for
it'll be nine years this fall that was
it was almost right out of college it's
pretty much a year - right out of
college and I've been writing since
college
and yeah I've I've literally worked from
home this entire time I'm working
remotely and I read anywhere from three
to five articles a day this week it's
been maybe like six you been smoking
today yeah this happens and I write
weekends I write holidays I write a lot
so I'm up to at least a couple thousand
articles over the last few years and a
couple hundred for destiny easily lately
and I've almost been doing daily destiny
articles because there's just there's so
much news so there's at least one thing
to write about per day with destiny
lately because they're really there
really hasn't been the kind of long
completely dead spells like we saw in
Destiny one like your two and three so
every day there's something you pumped
about man because how I came across you
I think all just like I said consistent
destiny information and then very candid
takes you know and you won even one
thing I like about your articles is that
um even if there's something I see the
tighted I'm like I don't know if I agree
with him on this when you actually read
your articles you make so much
compelling points that it's like you
know what I get I understand this dance
now I kind of get it now you know got it
and that's that's very talented as a
right I think thank you thank you yes
sometimes I even change my mind and I'll
completely go against my own take from
like a year all right so and then that's
not a tough question but the tough
question I know and DCP you were saying
what character you had been playing the
most so quick take on what has been your
recent character of use for all the
craziness going on oh man I I think I'm
more evenly split than most people like
I was checking my time and I guess
somehow I've become a hunter main in the
last like yeah you were we're luck and
then Titan and now yeah it's like by
like 50 hours or so I've been doing a
lot of like the exotic stuff on my
hunter like all the outbreak runs and
all that stuff was on hunter so that may
have boosted it up but I don't know I've
never been like a strong like this is my
class identity guy because I place so
much I get to play everything pretty
evenly so it just I don't know depends
on the state of the meta and like who's
overpowered or underpowered at any given
time but kind of play the glass the chat
is going critic on is in category I
gotta hear the dude now all the slander
no but at least you said you play all I
listen to them back I was like I'll
let's see what I can get from this just
to see and it was like well I used to
probably be warlock but now I checked
and I'm tight and literally right now
you're Hunter's like you've gone through
a rotation that's pretty crazy so it is
weird
all right well throws aside trying not
to take too long kind of gonna go
through this week chronologically
basically as things have been released
from Bungie so the first thing we got
this week was the director's cut part 1
as this is more passed stuff I don't
want to harp on it too long but there
are a couple pieces that I do want to
touch on for sure I know he talked a lot
about season The Drifter I was a major
piece that a lot of things they learned
from it they had gambit gamer Prime
reckoning and all these different things
they've learned so quick take and it
kind of got probably your answer Paul
from Wednesday as I caught fire team and
I think Cognito agrees as well but
gambit or game bit prime works way do
you guys lie I think I know the answer
but if you guys won't at least say it we
know where Paul is the list
I yeah I wrote a whole thing on this and
I know it's the minority opinion which I
was genuinely surprised was in that I
already opinion but I prefer og gambit I
think the main problem that most people
have with og gambit is that it's too
long but I think that's a pretty easy
problem to solve in the grand scheme of
things whereas if you keep Prime and
killed you gambit I think Prime is a lot
more issues that you have to address and
you have all the issues with the armor
sets and those kind of ending up being a
little bit mandatory so gambit becomes
more unfriendly to newer players that
are just trying to jump into it if they
haven't grinded out a bunch of tier 3
reckoning Prime sets I hate the primeval
phase preach it really annoying tug of
war they've nerfed it a little bit so
like it's not like an invader won't
totally bring you all the way back but
like it pretty much just comes down to
you like does your team know how to burn
at you know two stacks or whatever if
not you probably lose to the team that
does mm-hmm there's aspects of it I like
it just if I have to pick one I prefer
the simplified more standard version
than in prime because probably always
meant to be like a pinnacle version
where you may end up with some
combination of the two where they take
elements from both and and kind of mix
them but if I have to pick one it's
gotta be oh gee yeah I'm with I was
surprised too because I think when uh
even lose that a guardian calmly
speaking to it was Adam pin oh right yep
and um he actually he directly asked cuz
he's just one of his game Oh so you know
yeah I specifically say you don't which
guys like I think you were kind in the
middle right you were kind of well
that's where my question was gonna get
to you guys it's like yeah there's
things I like from both but yeah it's
like um I'm torn to the point where it's
like I like the idea of the sets like
having kind of diversity to it and as
for the like the boss mechanics I do
like how you can kind of set up your
damage phases not just like the damage
and I was actually having a debate with
my brother stoned like the other night
about gambit versus game at prime by the
way he's with you guys so I mean the
ones we talked to you seem to like
gambit I just like how the damage face
isn't oh is up so as soon as like
literally in-game but if you have your
Slayer high enough and as soon as that
invader goes you can you can burn the
boss and
a point where like the timing the
mechanics you can do that but then he
set on the other side well if so many
times the invasion just right they can
always like be there right when you're
starting so right it's a balance on both
sides that I don't know how the biggest
thing about gamba Prem that burned me is
the set bonuses for reckoning don't help
reckoning at all I was so annoyed that
you spend all this time in reckoning you
don't feel any more powerful in there
and it's like the whole way is just
bizarre I was like I love set bonuses
from like Diablo and World of Warcraft
and stuff like that and as it was so
finally in one area I was I was like
please more but yeah this is definitely
not enough so mines always been the
frustration that the sets have never
been a broader thing that they've used
would you man I mean I think there are
some aspects of prime I do enjoy but um
I think I'd like to ask the idea of this
set I think it was a cool idea constant
but I get frustrated during the primeval
phase because it's like I just feel like
the invasions become it's almost like an
annoying part of of it and it just
interrupts the flow I I can't really
describe it
whereas gambit you know I think if
you're a little bit more coordinated it
can go faster and I don't I just I just
feel like will stress level wise I just
I just really enjoy standard gambit it
just it just feels like a more fun mode
and I think the rounds kind of Li still
have the UM
so you know I like it but hopefully I
will see you know then even merge some
combination of the two I'm very curious
to see what wins because unfortunately
Paul I saw that poem is not going in our
favor right now yeah I don't know if I'm
just gonna do straight up like majority
vote or whatever if they see enough of
those polls but I feel like they're
gonna if if it is prime if they pick
prime which is apparently what most
people want I feel like they're gonna
have to do some pretty major changes to
it to make it like less pinnacle and it
is now and whether that's what the sets
or like the primeval phase or whatever
like I'm not opposed to I guess the
concept of a one rounds gambit match I
just wish the mechanics of it were more
like og gambit than what we have in
prime so again maybe they can blend it
and it'll be okay but if it's just like
standard prime forever and oh geez dead
like that's
one last thing eat I just feel that one
round takes so long they say it's one
round but it really goes on a while did
the push/pull can can really you know
she can train notes train and tomorrow
it's so much to it that again in theory
it sounds just one round but there's a
lot going on that can really elongate
the match and part of that I guess is
when you get to the drain mode so it's
like it's it is kind of annoying but
also it does make you at least kind of
stay active in the middle yeah like
there is some like strategy to like put
into this job you can just sit there and
stay on the outside and farm stuff and
then wipe it all at once like if you do
then you've let that stuff go away but
actually like Paul like one of your
articles that I really like the idea
that I think it'd be a nice alternate
all most if they do kind of you know
make the highlander of gambits when you
said a PvE only then he actually was I
really liked that idea and it's one
thing that would be take the invasion
out of it just make it a PvE race that'd
be a way to make them different if they
push those two together but still give
some variety in that activity
I don't know a thing about that wouldn't
be like that's how gambit is now it
would be kind of like a beginner's
gambit mode where like okay who take
normal gambit be able to do that and
like I don't think you should like even
gain infamy from that or like it the
same kind of rewards but if there's like
a quest where it's like play ten gambit
matches like you could do that version
and it would also introduce people to
some of the more like beginner people to
the more complicated mechanics of gambit
without having them constantly be killed
by you know truth invaders so I don't
think they'll do it like I thought I
like that I'm using it to be nice and
that's one thing I guess in this game
they have enough popups on screen I wish
the first time somebody played gambit
there'd be like I see her a couple pop
ups that would be like hey you've played
game but this is how Prime Evils work
and what they do just a couple things
that tell the initial players that would
help I think would go a long ways as
long as you have a tutorial gambit
quests at least absolute just like
anything preach I agree you're gonna
have a lot of new light players learning
this thing and they're about to have a
really rough go at it I think yeah
mm and then next piece we had obviously
game bit Prime the other side of that
coin is reckoning and as they go through
and Luke Smith talks about the reckoning
he basically said the first time he
played with Phoenix protocol he knew it
was over and that kind of gets into the
bigger problem where they've kind of
been nerfing supers and exotics and kind
of the idea of stacking damage buffs and
things like that but also they made this
encounter because of the supers and the
exotics they built so I'm not gonna go
full into what they were talking about
with like enemy design and encounter and
stuff I would ask you guys as this is
their current mentality now and this is
the state we are in where do you guys
think we are going into shadow keep with
regards to how powerful we feel we're
gonna have potentially less damage
stacking and things like that we may
hear about later today where do you guys
think our current you know we can go on
to reckoning and basically stand there
and feel like a god how do you guys
think it's gonna be in shadow keep with
what they've learned in the past six
months it's good tested I definitely
think we're headed for a well luna
faction rally barricade nerf like
absolutely they've mentioned that they
don't they don't like the constant like
unloading of everything without having
to reload that may also come into play
with some of the damage stacking stuff
so it's not just like every boss phase
is stack the buffs unload everything you
got and like pretty much new kid on the
spot without the need for because
otherwise to combat that that you have
bosses with like more and more immunity
phases or they run able to do crazy
mechanics like The Reckoning where
you're being spammed from both sides but
snipers and stop bosses and thrall and
now let's not I mean you could really
see how that an encounter was designed
specifically around well which is
exactly that's a crazy way to design
anything and like that's a point like I
everyone hates nerves but like I would
rather have well be nerve and then have
an activity where well it's like pretty
much 100% mandatory to make it work in
any capacity with randoms
and so I I mean I will miss it I guess
but we'll have our or Albert a tiny
funeral and
you kind of just get tired of feeling
like you only can do the same things
over and over again we use the same
builds and productivity like that we're
like that thing was mandatory I'm a
little concerned about that although I
find it ironic that we're getting like
weapons of light tight and bubble back
right as you say maybe that maybe
they're okay with like damage most they
just don't want it to be like infinite
you know stuff I don't know I'll say
yeah yeah I think what you guys I mean
first of all shout out to Luke with the
transparency man because one thing about
this whole all these directors cuts I
have to give Bungie so much credit man
like I've never seen you know I'm so
amazed I've been around a while okay and
I've never seen that level of
transparency honesty and it goes to show
you like your reckoning was designed
around that whole super and that exotic
just to try to make it challenge and I
feel for them on the design level right
you really feel for them but they have
to go through all these things to try to
circumvent something that makes you kind
of stand in this stationary spot and be
kind of vulnerable and then load and
they also he actually combined the
whisper or the worm talk in there and
how you know how they had to bring that
back and they almost wish they didn't
you know bring it in and it's an initial
phase in destiny to I think they kind of
felt pressure to the fact that destiny 2
started off we didn't feel powerful and
they kind of fell into that trap we got
to give him something and then that's
the West but but um yeah we lost our
sure we know coming shadow key there's
definitely gonna be some nurse is that
we saw it I I think even like it might
hit skull of diam Cara you know kind of
levels of of nerf that was a bad one
that was a bit but I got it you know why
I got it
because then like right after they
introduced juju could you imagine juju
skull I wanted to go to just change into
something else because like I just
didn't want it to be like oh now you get
20% of your super instead of a hundred
because I just killed it I'd rather just
have it you tweaked into something more
inclined good point and I'm worried
that's what they'll do with Phoenix
protocol too but yeah that's actually a
great point in in in reference to again
if you're gonna nerf that ability
is really not going to be a desired
exotic right so at some point you made a
great point ball which is change the
functionality make it do something else
so it still has function and it's not
just relying on super energy or
regeneration but all in all it's cool to
see them talk about this and how they're
gonna move with boss encounters we're
moving yeah I mean you guys pretty much
covered everything it was just crazy
when you think of matchmaking into
reckoning for one depending on the day
that the modifier was was like nope
because if it's like out no yeah
blackout no was like plus you'll meet a
class with snipers and we'll just make
it glass blackout and I can just kiss my
own but I mean the modifiers were one
but it's too as you say like if you
think about going random it's a match
made place but if you go match made into
there and you're like hey I want to run
chaos reach Golden Gun and hammers here
you guys that you guys are all screwed
like if you go in without that and it's
in that text way as you said you forced
people to play a certain way and that's
not what they want so again they've
learned a lot in the past six months it
has been an interesting journey I'm not
gonna harp too much on this one because
we have so much to talk about for armor
I do want to say a quick shout out what
do you guys think of the new look on the
pursuits tab better think it's better I
still wish there was a quicker way to
access it on console rather than on ps4
you have to hit the center pad and then
scroll over and I know pcs getting a
hotkey but man yeah I agree the people
definitely said yeah we just got to get
you on PC so he's working on you a lot
of people I just thought that was
hilarious when Luke walks in is like
have you read it and they're like what
no please don't read it oh yeah that's
your game dry can be like we're so sorry
let's be honest it was kind of do you
know the way it was just brought in yeah
it was kind of rough it was kind of
rough man that extra it's just so
annoying they hit that extra button and
it you just and you need bounties and
you know pursuits keep rearranging the
order
yes oh wow where did my quest go yeah
that was that was the best part and also
we've got a touch on ever verse for one
that's going to the director so I don't
know if Tessa's just like out of a job
did they like kick her to the curb are
we just gonna like interact with her in
orbit what do you guys think it's
probably both thanks I mean they just
want store to be able to be accessed
from anywhere that's kind of a common
game thing now where they just let it
let you find it from the menu no matter
what like anthem does that like I think
the division does that too it's you can
go to a vendor but you can also just hit
a button yeah but it did seem like they
were handling it well I mean if you have
three or five pieces you get a 60%
discount it seems to be going in the
right direction but it did kind of
appreciate and if you're wondering
that's probably the sound by the way cuz
that's just a follow when they actually
said they're like whispered the worm's
ornaments paid for zero-hour yeah that
was cool that was it's cool to hear
directs kind of results like that mm-hmm
absolutely and like I said we've had
this discussion many times and you know
you know that technically they're
independent studio right now right so
it's just like they're in India sure
sure you get a small indie guy hundred
but yeah man like what I hear stuff like
that I have no problems you know
supporting a game again way it's not
affecting the gameplay it's going
directly to the studio we know since the
split you know going to them and I
actually when I saw that information we
put that out there I thought that was
really cool that that was able to fund
that cuz let's be on our I mean for the
most part I was just already done yeah
so as they're independent now and you
see stuff like that are you more willing
to sometimes I mean you may just buy
them all anyway but are you more willing
to at least them back your mind be like
feel a little better about it if you
normally would buy it
does it help knowing that they're
independent where you know the money's
going to them for me personally you know
well they poco yeah it's I mean I I was
pretty much buying all the ornaments I
wanted anyway even in the imaginary take
every time but I mean I'd overall I
liked the the idea of direct purchases
more I think I think it's good they're
moving away from loot box engrams it is
gonna result and probably fewer things
just given up for free overall but I
think targeted buying of things is good
and I think there probably will be more
people that are more willing to buy
stuff now that they hear things like oh
if I buy this I'm funding the next
dungeon instead of just giving money to
Activision so exactly indeed so that's
kind of a general big touches on part
one it's a great read if you guys
haven't read it so please do it's
awesome to see his words Kennedy he's
got a good sense of humor too everything
about it I mean and it's also an appoint
where you see a game director says yeah
this wasn't good I mean when they
acknowledge something when the whole
community tends to say it as well it's
nice of them to say yeah this isn't
great or I put this feels way too
overpowered they went through a lot of
the same things we do they just can't
make the changes of fastest of course
tomorrow which everybody wants it to be
so after director's cut part 1 we now
come to Armour 2.0 and I think this is
gonna be obviously a big piece of the
discussion I did a video about you know
Armour 2.0 in about five minutes that
was a struggle but it squeezy we've got
a lot of stuff to cover so first from
that whole stream what are some of the
things that you guys are excited about
from that just a couple things that you
see as you know potential for like a
good thing coming out of that stream and
then also we'll get to the two downsides
maybe but what do you guys think you're
excited about from that stream um for me
I'd say when this first hit I was like a
little mixed on it but the more I think
about it the more I'm kind of excited
about it overall which is the fact that
almost all the armor in the game can be
armor 2.0 now and I know that you can't
just like pull it from collections like
maybe that would make sense but the fact
that you really are gonna have a huge
range of cosmetics now because it's
pretty much every armor set in the game
outside of like factions and trials and
yeah I don't maybe the rebel reset I
don't know but so just to hear that yeah
I got a regrind some stuff or whatever
but at least I will have the ability to
to have my cosmetics be that wide and I
was worried that they were gonna just be
like oh yeah we have you know these your
your three sets and like we're gonna
slowly introduce here one in two sets
like trickling it out like they kind of
do the old gun so where they lay their
hands there's like three new guns from
all time so
overall I think I think it's that's good
news even though initially I was like I
gotta do all five weeks of EP again yeah
I do think that's that's good news over
on that's I mean that's just one point
but Owen you guys go Cognito what do you
got yeah listen it was I didn't know
what to expect I came in with very
tempered expectations you know I'm gonna
ask you because I know this is your this
is your jam this is what you your heart
was set on this but you know for me it
was one of those things let me see how
they're gonna evolve and I thought was
an interesting approach in a sense that
you know the thing I was concerned about
was okay what happens to year you know
prior armor and they're saying no you
can keep that that can still coexist
with you know you're with the new set
you don't win it we're not forcing a
transition on you you know we expect you
at some point to ease off because let's
be honest me we all have you know a
bunch of gear set with like you know
such double scavenger perks and you know
said you you know the the bills that we
currently have that I'm really grateful
yeah I know your fault crazy and then
just think about you know the guys with
the five you know super mod stacks or
goodnight watch that shot my boy fall
out you got the you got the disgusting
controverse whole bills right now he's
like he's not a good person you know
they're but you know it's one of those
things that I like that did it they
introduces something new but they're not
forcing it you know and the first thing
I saw was just like okay we have that
option that options as far as
customization you know and that whole
call most like a pic 10 kind of a system
where you know you kind of placing
things but hey hey you can't have this
and you can't have this and then they
letting you know you know so overall I'm
cool with it I was a little concerned
about the arc element thing at first I
was like how's that gonna work I know
Tasi you touched on that you know and
should blaze article today won't we'll
get back to you but um overall man I
have to say like I'm I'm feeling really
good about getting armor each having its
own specific stat role and then kind of
playing so almost each drop is gonna be
meaningful and that kind of excites me
so overall I was pretty good it II it's
on you I can't wait this what I'm
waiting for all week I want to hear my
mani BOTS
what is your feeling on this because you
had high expectations so the thing that
got me the most of the fact that you can
see your ghost behind you or your ghost
in your sparrow in the infant no I'm
just kidding that is really cool that's
one of those little little things when
they brought it up I was like oh that
looks cool like that was one of those
things I did not expect actually um for
me Armour 2.0 is first we got the stats
back so now we got six that's to work
with we're feeling definitely more the
RPG feel because you've got you know
resistance reload really you know
ability recharge times things like that
are all a big deal you've got the tears
everything they talked about in the
stats mine is as I get deeper I want to
know more questions kind of wondering so
I know like your salsa set if people do
it is gonna be your first set cool you
get a set roll okay now my curiosity is
they say the stats are gonna be randomly
rolled is it gonna be out of a certain
amount or you actually gonna be able to
get like a god roll because if you see
look at the bottom of any of the armor
stats
it'll say like total number it kind of
barely has basically a total number
below it'll be like 60 and then when
they master work them they don't went up
to 72 or something like that I'm
honestly wondering like do all Helms
have 60 stats or their homes that can
roll with a total of 60 total of 70
maybe total of 80 and is that where the
grind is gonna be so that's a question
we don't have an answer to but that's
what I'm really curious about to know
hey maybe does the radar more have a
higher loop or a higher stat pool to
distribute over the stats mmm that's
like the bigger question I've got with
regards to the solar the arc the void as
I'm going through it I was like oh this
is kind of then I thought about it more
like I don't know and then we kind of
people have been digging into and then
Luke's tweet yesterday talking about I
won't steal your thunder but the you're
gonna have a little more variety then we
kind of thought we would but you're
gonna be limited somebody else who said
if I want to run risk runner with like
an arc resistance that's not gonna be
there because though the submachine guns
are gonna be so there are certain
limitations to the builds but I do like
thank God for me in my vault that yes
generally you're gonna be able to keep
one of each type of armor a solar and
are can avoid whatever fits your
playstyle the best and have one of each
of those you don't have to have 19
different helmets to hope you have a
sniper rifle loader washer rockets
sub-bands
rifle you just pick and choose and it's
500 glimmer and shout out to the glimmer
cap increase we got 250,000 big one
that's huge that's huge so overall I
don't I'm not I'm not getting
ringing endorsement I'm not this praise
that I thought I was really hated it was
like okay I love the fact that you can
customize that you can take a piece of
art and be like hey I want machine guns
right now I'm switching over
BAM 500 glimmer and you're probably
gonna have and you can switch that stuff
over you don't have to have 50 different
sets which is great but mine is more as
I think about it more it's just some
questions that I've got so it's just
wondering how how deep that did they
dive into the RPG it's like do all
helmets have 72 stats just just
distribute it across of them or are
there actual rolls when you pick up one
it's got 59 the other it's got 71 you're
like well hell yeah this one's better
that's a question more than anything but
I do like the fact that now when I pick
up any piece of armor it's gonna be
worth a look
because I gotta know is it the right
class is it or energy type and is it
gonna be worth maybe better it's that
role or not and I'm not gonna be burned
too much if it's like everything 70 like
everything's a set amount per like helm
example but I will I hope there's some
variety there but because you are still
gonna go for builds but once you kind of
get your build if and you can't get
those a little bit higher it is gonna
lower some of the longevity of things so
says he seems like he's ready to he's
chomping at the bit on well I'm trying
to I don't know if this is an answer to
your question or not but I I know that
it was said in the lucema thing that I
think maybe it's from yesterday where
you can get armor rolls where you can
have like max discipline yes without
mods but I don't know if that means like
you have like zero in every other stat
it's like you said and some pieces can
just roll flat out better than others
and like I wouldn't I would hope that's
the system because like if everything
just has like 50 or 60 points or
whatever it is like distributed among
all the stats and there's no little bars
move and I know none is like clearly
better than any other unless it's just
one bar you like is higher I think it
would be better to have some up to a
cap of like 70 or 80 or whatever it is
that that's the kind of thing you're
grinding for because one of my
fundamental questions with this entire
system is okay if armor can if Cosmetics
are out the window like what is really
the point of grinding armor now if
everything is just empty slots right so
the two answers to that are stat rolls
but we sell questions on that and then
then the elemental system which is kind
of awkward and I think it's confusing in
a few ways like it's clearly confusing
because people are planning about it and
now we don't know if we should be
complaining about it but without that
there would be a lot that's at least
like kind of tripling the grind as arise
you only like trying to grind for just
different stat bar increases or
decreases so I understand why it's in
place I just think it's a little awkward
and confusing and we're probably just
gonna have to see it and practiced and
know how it feels and if it's I think we
all get used to it pretty quickly but
and I can see like new players showing
up and be like oh I have this like solar
fusion rifle loader icon like that's not
gonna work for my arc fusion rifle right
and like it's your own systems are
connected but the point is some kind of
confusing yeah as effects to it but I
don't know maybe maybe you'll just get
used to it over time yeah I mean you
know I think yeah definitely it's gonna
be one of things we're gonna have to get
hands on with it and then you know get
acclimated I think from me the key that
I like was just like being a master
working to me actually has value I like
some yeah that's a huge it cuz we all
know currently as master things I mean
I'm not spending that you did the math
or and how much resources needed to do
for such a you know you know incremental
kind of a boost so that part I like I do
like the versatility of having for
example like you know a linear future
right if I won't you know scavenger and
another weaponry loader and having that
kind of flexibility I thought that was
cool
I like the aspects that some of the
armor is gonna come in so you might get
something that drops at a seven you
might suddenly get something drops out
of fire that kind of thing and then
obviously we assuming clinical sources I
know we'll get to that are gonna be
really important for cuz one thing I
hate it was like you know when
can only get it was so hard to get
something like enhanced targeting
acquisition or something that's really
desirable so now that they're making
that clear path to say okay pinnacle
activities are going to be where a lot
of this stuff kind of resides that that
excites me so again a lot of questions I
agree you know I think overall and I
think what's cool about them what I like
today are doing is they're saying look
we're not even sure if this is you know
the way so to speak we still can't they
still saying to us as a studio they're
finding their way with this stuff but I
think the evolution towards MMO is in
the in the right path so I'm gonna give
it a shot we see I see how it goes the
system is easy to fix to sewing if it
becomes too restrictive all they have to
do is be like alright we're gonna do arc
and void copies of this arc mod yeah and
like you can grind for those not to like
the end that's pretty much all they
would need to do fix diversity if if
that's even necessary so I think they
have a lot of options and a lot of
flexibility with the new system
completely great I was like I do like
the idea that now you can I mean as she
I think it was Lisa on stream she
specialized pretty heavy in the linear
fusions but it was hey I want to go
reserves on linear fusions scavenger
hunt I want to always make sure I've got
ammo and she was running around and she
had it all the time you can't like
double triple stack per se mhm
but they but Luke second piece part two
actually did say or was the tweet I
forget which one have red tunity the
base armor is gonna plague basically
start it with your generic roles of like
large arm small arms rifles you're gonna
have your basic roles that come with it
and then you'll unlock the more
specialized than the idea is they're
cheaper so like if you go a larger arms
loader yeah it works on a lot of things
but it's going to take more energy to
use you're not going to use it quite as
much so dr. bender to chat real quick he
actually said at the point I think we
all didn't say that stuff is not
consumable that's the best change that's
that we just yeah thank you by the way
totally thanks bender yay once you
unlock it's yours you can move around
that's cool I like that that creates I
mean with with the pinnacle things for
enhanced stuff like those are going to
be some of the most valuable drops in
the game now
Thanks just because of how widely
available they are and his permanent
unlocks like once you get enhanced
sniper targeting you can put that on
literally anything all your loading all
year long so I am hoping that they're
not going to do like okay enhance sniper
is is exclusive to the raid and you can
only drive in and then I'm hoping
there's like a pool and then there was
like a pinnacle activity collection
that's like right your banner raids like
menagerie and then some new activity or
something where you at least can like me
that's what I'm gonna throw in I of it
look at him look at him yeah oh yeah
don't you that'd be perfect to like
something else you can grind for that
isn't like okay I have to grind iron pan
or just to get you know enhanced loader
of whatever so hopefully they know that
that would be bad but we don't have any
confirmation on that yet yeah and it's
nice the specialization it is
interesting though you look it through
because I'm assuming the stream it may
not you know take it with a grain of
salt there could be changes between now
and release but with what we see if
they're gonna show us they're usually
pretty close to what they're working
with and you even take things modifiers
like ashes to assets and enhanced bomber
those are solar based and those are on
the class item but their solar like
that's I mean like reactive for my
fusions man I'm causing damage with that
right there I got a crazy build in PvP
briny that's the one I need so back I'm
just discussing just getting super back
oh I think I'm wondering honestly and
this is where I kind of wonder as
they're gonna let you use old and new
and they've moved some of the perks
around reserves typically like the big
reserves like machine guns rockets
grenades the big ones are sitting on
your helmet so I wonder if anybody saves
like hey I've got sniper reserves on an
old helm but they stack it with like a
new chest and they put reserves there's
that how they're gonna be able to double
stack now I'm wondering if people save
some of that old stuff and they're able
to break some things that way or if
they're doing a bit like reserves are
capped at one no matter where you get
from I don't know name I guess but they
haven't said yet yeah I had a question -
what happens to ADA with her specific
pool of black Audrey mods right like I
know that I don't get the vibe they're
getting but um she's got a unique pool
you know ring so I'm just curious how
that works you know she I'm assuming gun
sniff is still gonna be a source a lot
of the new mods but will she be reworked
is she's gonna stay
I mean Oh get me wrong I know problem go
get model she's more vector much though
right she's oh yeah what I would hope
yeah cuz that's aren't they all weapon
mods for yes it is all weapon but I'm
just curious
scourge of the past or taken armaments
you're talking more that type of stuff
that too but I'm just again because the
vibe I used to the vibe I'm getting is
of they are slowly transitioning us away
you know from that right now initially
but slowly so I guess is my question is
is her role going to stay exactly the
same
or will she evolve and also provide
other thing because to be honest like I
go to her regular okay I go get my
components you know saying I'm getting
things from her so I'm just curious
it how her role changes diminishes arm
just basis a my guess is that she won't
change for this but if if they end up
doing guns 2.0 and they at least change
the gun system to use permanent unlock
mods I would hope that they wouldn't
just scrap her and the day would like
see ya just kick her out of the tower
robot but I would hope that there would
be some sort of new black armory grind
where you grind the forges for like
rampage spec or you know as a permanent
unlock and like I don't there'd be no
reason not to do that and it would even
give people the reason to do old content
and if axe so and the stuff that's like
taking armaments and stuff that's
probably a more immediate concern
because yeah my guess is that they're
just not gonna automatically be like oh
yeah there's a permanent taken armaments
mod you can online raid like go nuts
like that would be cool I just see that
happening you know in order to use those
you might still have to be using like
your two armor but yeah
I don't know if we'll say do you think
those are gonna be like if you go back
and run crown of sorrow for example do
you think you're gonna be able to get
any of those as a permanent unlock or is
that gonna be incentive to run I don't
think so
you don't think so it would be nice
sounds like I wonders you don't think so
though I don't know well that would be
so he's so powerful they have that
zapper cause like think about it was
right just for those and to get a
permanent like taking on everything it's
a game-changing occasion and I was
already posed a valuable thing in the
game you could even get because of how
yours absolutely yeah and like I'm all
for I think it'd be cool but I have a
hard time seeing that happening here we
go we got yeah I was gonna say that's
about the if the drop is rarer than
anything in the game but I also think
game but would be ultra broken again so
yes if that's one of the reasons why
they might kind of steer away from those
is to help see how gambit does I mean if
you don't run foot you can run a stack
of people who are organized and talk and
still stack your damage which they're
gonna talk about but if you don't have
mods and people running around I've I
don't even have any of those mods for
taken and I still sometimes happen to
have two hundred bullets of machine gun
I'm like this is like kind of broken
mode that should be competitive or I
could just dump all the damage so yeah
heavy was a big thing in game game but
that'll be but yeah taking those mods
out for everything will be they want you
to transition and they're not gonna
force you but it is gonna be interesting
when that time comes that everybody's
mostly on year three where those mod sit
if they're just turning into mod
components or what yeah last point I'm
actually now more incentivized to do
Leviathan all the old raised to get the
newer versions of of that arm I'm really
pumped about that cuz I gotta get some
stuff done I got some catalyst I get a
you gotta win the fashion contest they
throw me I need my shade is but I gotta
get in this I'm that now incentivize me
to wait the shadow keep run those old
Ray's baby get that stuff I hope I hope
we're moving towards a permanent shader
unlock system like that is logical that
has to happen
I'm sure there's like technical
difficulties or whatever it's their
separate systems but like clearly that
would be a game system yes
all yeah yeah that's so sick and sweet
you're watching me go through each piece
I'm like oh you're asthmatic redesign
that wasn't the focus yeah that was just
apply to all button be like and it's
just on the main screen just have like a
shader in the corner and you can go up
and just apply it to everything you got
just straight up you're like I want to
be black armory mod done it may take a
minute to load that's okay if you're on
console but it but you don't want to go
to collections and by black armory apply
it to each of them so we've got
Universal ornaments as we're kind of
talking about cosmetics anyway a lot of
that do you guys I'm thinking is gonna
be mostly universe ornaments are the
ever sets you've earned over the past
couple of years is that it from the
previous discussion that's what most all
that's coming from I think so - a couple
things maybe like the old iron banner
ornaments or the old like crucible or
something like that so I'm mad at do I
go get my new monarchy I need that I
like I like the idea I think they're
gonna my prediction faction based season
at some point and that's how I think
they're gonna bring that stuff back then
in theory they should make factions kind
of a permanent fixture in the yeah it
used to be I bet it would be introduced
in something like that
oh so man I need my head a Oh shade is I
need that gold I need all my premium
looks man that's my face I'm everyone to
that faction just for the shame just
just put it out okay I still I still use
other faction shaders well exact it's a
future work because like these are
futuristic like will the future people
in the future blind and then you got
like the premium gold chili inhaler man
oh it's like you got you got Gryffindor
that's got its epic nature you got slow
there in its black and green and then
all of a sudden like Hufflepuff comes in
the background
taste the rainbow we slander a future
walk all right
sorry Locke you know she's she's not
happy right now up in her little future
bunker space chairs oh yeah so Luke
election god I totally was thinking I
was like I haven't been up in the little
space bunker with the pod chair things
and stuff like they look tell me it all
look like a Starbucks and they got Wi-Fi
up in Chris be read-only like a
Starbucks think of anything else for the
armor so we've got the energy types
which as you said will be kind of one of
your roles we've got set mods the chill
unlock that'll just kind of slot in you
won't be able to double stack but the
energy will be there so what do you guys
think this is I guess the other piece I
was trying to get to the new currencies
we've got to get how cuz already like
enhancement cores for infusion not
everybody loves which is still probably
looking like it's gonna be there and
then now these are gonna be your master
work and now you only say you master
work like three sets of armor you don't
have to do it as often but those new
currencies they said they might be tied
to things like night falls and stuff
like that and they said they don't want
them to be famine but I haven't usually
seen that stuff be too generous either
so I was curious you guys thoughts on
the new currencies since they are
introducing two more because we don't
have enough already
I get why they did it it's so people who
have like 2000 enhancement cores that
they either got legitimately or
illegitimately you can't afford I spam
them all and and tier 10 masterwork
everything that's that's what he's
hoping for that one I guess yeah it is
it's interesting because - you're
telling stuff is gonna be very important
going forward because that's how you're
gonna get the max amount of good mods so
it will be a commitment to use those
kind of final stage things to get there
I think it's like the last three levels
or something like you have to require
eight nine attic prisons and then cores
and then ascended to sendin things so
yeah and that seems like something
that's probably going to be in pinnacle
or
weekly milestones so you get a set
amount if you if you show up every week
I mean hopefully they've learned some
kind of lessons from the enhancement
core nonsense and like that's been
mostly solved with bounties so it's not
that bad anymore but if if they learn
those lessons and then don't just
completely starve people right I think
it'll be okay and I get why they did it
but I mean we're gonna have to see how
it how it is when it shows up and so my
guess is it might take a couple weeks to
earn enough for at least your first full
tier ten set like I don't even know if
you'll get enough send in orbs or
whatever it is shards that's right but
in in week one - like - you're ten asset
right off the bat so yeah that's another
reason they're probably gonna have these
to delay progression a little ways into
the city agreed I completely see it as a
design choice because of guys like
Yvonne says these cars has all these
things that spin them that's different I
have like 500 and I don't even have as
many as some people on Twitter so these
days but not all jokes aside III think
you nailed it I think that's exactly the
reason I think that um the key is you
know one would hope they've learned a
lesson with the whole enhancement Corps
thing you know as far as sources you
know now we finally getting a good place
you do your gunsmith bounties you're
able to get a consistent source and you
know of them and I'm hoping that they
you know it's gonna be not something
that's so scarce to get that final level
you know that you may be able to mass
work stuff but I think they're gonna
they're gonna slow us in the beginning
you're gonna make it kind of like a
pinnacle kind of thing but we'll see I
think it I think it's the right call
overall I'm not too upset with that's
what you what about you yeah it's like I
think it's just gonna make you think a
little more or you'll kind of be doing
the stuck in a place that a little while
as you look think about exotics because
those aren't gonna be cheap to do and
you're not just gonna yeah switch out
exotics quickly mm-hmm it's gonna take
master working the other side master
working another piece of armor if you
find a new exotic for the kind of fits
your playstyle you're probably going to
live with
for a little while I would imagine yeah
real quick how do we feel about the
exotics full amount of collection having
different roles right that that's gonna
go in there set role now well it's set
role in the sense like it'll have a set
element in the set stat distribution but
it's gonna be 2.0 in the sense where it
has blank slots to playing slash so to
speak yeah so I think that's good
because no one wants to what well you
could earn all the legendary armor no
one wants to go and rear in like 50 60
armor exotics like that one yeah very
disappointing so I think that's that's a
good and they did that when they when
they went to armor armor 1.0 from year 1
to year yes yes where you could pull it
from collections and it would have at
least some fixture all they're usually
bad rolls terrible they off him yeah IMO
finder and everything very there mm-hmm
but didn't they split ammo finder into
like each day ah so you can spend less
ammo finders now and they have the
special boxes that are on the ground
from the preview so don't they not have
that for primary there's no like pulse
rifle ammo finder is there yeah there
was like her for all the primaries -
yeah I never I don't run out of primary
I don't have anybody like that unless
yeah what sustenance or substance or
something assistance yeah I always mix
it up but that's about the only time
yeah well that one and then if you use
any if you just hold down recluses about
the only other time but haha generally
I'm not really running out a hand cannon
ammo in a normal PvE fight that's not
something I'm dying for so those always
kind of make me wonder now especially
like ammo finders for special and heavy
yeah bring it all day because under
needs and rockets and stuff specifically
sure but the the primaries I don't I
don't think so
I like the finder system where it shows
you which ammo is generated years now
everyone is like is this working is this
broken me but it was probably just R&D
but you can't sell and I think it would
like to fix heavy ammo finder cuz nobody
knew if it worked
yeah do I know for remember they were
like people were saying it was this was
a disadvantage if you ran too
and all this stuff based on reading are
we gonna get a ruin wings back and then
we can see like little wings on the ammo
boxes actually a good way segue to bring
it bring it back yeah you plan to you
guys a good call I'm planning what I
said taken up definitely coming back and
it has to come back wanna keep trekking
distracting to rocket hey it fits
thematically with the rule like it has
to come back those are two good woods
it would seem fitting let's just say
that yeah yeah so I'm trying to think of
anything else for the stream we actually
have been moving decently fast I mean I
will say the one lingering kind of
temporary disappointment I have with
ARMA 2.0 is that fundamentally we
haven't seen any new mods yeah it's just
I'm not sure like we know that like the
artifact is gonna introduce like
temporary mods that are gonna be cool
that could be added but from what we
know right now it's pretty much all the
same mods that we already have just kind
of rearranged and the more customization
so like a new customization system is
cool but I think one of the problems
with out with armor has always been that
it's just not the mods aren't that
exciting it's like thinking they're
helpful like you can reload faster you
can you can aim better you can a couple
of them are like super regenerating
button like like we've seen with guns
guns have been introducing at least some
new perks over time right right
you know swashbuckler and mm-hmm multi
kill clipping like they're through these
adding new stuff in in the mix and one
we just haven't seen anything like that
yet so fundamentally like we might have
like lower cooldowns it's like the thing
that you notice the most mm-hmm but I
don't know how much gameplay is actually
gonna change unless there's a bunch of
like hidden awesome mods that we don't
see and we might even lose some mod
functionality if we're not getting
things like the the take in or high for
though those kind of mods bags no good
point good point
that's a good option I mean I guess the
question I have you know with with rage
I mean you've gone back and forth for
this you know with d1 and how we use
getting armor that gave that kind of
encourage specific raid mechanics and to
help you with raid mechanics and I feel
since d2 is launched you know they tried
to reintroduce it later with Leviathan
and you know doing a little extra energy
bumps and damage Bluffs and grenades
though but I never felt since d2 is
launched that raid armor has perks that
actually help you with the mechanics of
the raid and I really hope they somehow
get back to it I just don't know how to
implement it because I missed that I
missed doing rapid machine and you know
you had did the damage reduction with
the bomb stuff or you know whatever it
was that it was a mechanic you know you
know since fall you know shooting the
arc doing more damage to Oracle's that
kind of stuff incentivized the gear it
made it even more worthwhile and
rewarded you for continually running the
activity so I would hope at some point
they get back to that I'm just concerned
it may be an afterthought I don't know
what you guys think no I mean it's the
thing that was pretty generic it's like
20 20 percent solar damage on the buy
something so mmhmm yeah I don't really
know I think I rid of that yeah I miss
that man I really do like you're
standing in this well you reload faster
and you know stuff there's a badge and
stuff like that you're in the callous
plate you get billed 5% extra damage
buff it's just something that gets back
to the mechanics you know I'm saying and
it really rewards you I really missed
that I mean even in callous you can have
a you could get goofy with the buff and
just say hey if you're wearing five
pieces like every piece is 2% but it's
like if you're cursed cuz you're just
flipping a buff back and forth in there
well say if you're cursed you you take a
little less damage if you're not cursed
you do a little more damage or something
like that just a way to give you
incentive to be why would I wear all
five pieces if I don't have perfect
rolls on those pants what to say you
just which transitions give me my next
thought and I normally go on long on
this but the the whole you know how we
feel about armor sets and I think one
division does well is armor set bonuses
because as of right now there's no
incentive to take off an exotic armor
right there's no incentive but imagine
if we had that I mean gambit prime was
the closest we've gotten right where you
to set on and each one gives you some
type of statistical bump for that
activity we kind of need to get back to
that because it's such a cool mechanic I
just wish they kind of stole that from
the Risen I love that division really
does that mm-hmm
slow-mo in the chat already what is
division that's the biggest thing for me
that I've wanted since and they teased
it too with gambit and it was like oh
you can use it on one bubble in your
director I'm like I have like 50 more
what about those so for me it's been say
if I go to the European dead zone and
Deborah McKay has a set that's gonna
help me with fallen damage and what
somebody would be like well what if that
helps you in a future raid against
fallen I'm like then so be it but that's
incentive to go back to that planet
that's exactly what you want I'm gonna
go play on the European dead zone it's
supposed to be like bye and you know you
could go to Titan for hive and you could
pick a planet and have the vendor do
that those types of things I think would
be really really good and they've missed
kind of an opportunist ette bonuses work
and I think that was the first time to
test that it can't
mmm so I just really want maybe in
future seasons if they start to open up
like the world vendors yeah they're
gonna have armor 2.0 and stats but I
don't know if there's still much reason
to go to them but as you said like I'm
hoping there's you know Aris on the moon
please tell me there's something for
there should be a hive bonus for like
getting the armor from her or the raid
armor something along those lines would
be even a full salsa salsa stay it looks
so cool you meet just give us a little
extra bonus I'm wearing all five you
know like it would be so cool man I
really want that so bad yep so I think
somehow we actually got through armor a
lot faster than I thought we would
there's a lot to cover there but we've
been serious come on yeah so big one
director's cut too we are talking about
the future now so a couple things that
we argue it's been a busy year so he
said let's recap obviously but a date
and it's like the care and feel of
feeding the RPG it's like add depth
improved customization so he goes into a
little bit about armor which we've
touched on but he did make that
clarification the first thing I guess
there was some confusion with regards to
microtransactions and armor sets and
stuff like that those are still gonna be
there and I think he was very
emphatic to make that clear to say
you're still gonna be able to earn your
moon armor sets and things like that
and he mentioned one thing I don't know
if you guys caught it it's gonna go - I
made a sweet set of astro shaman gear at
the rune table
that's a nice little team that has to be
for the moon because for what I read I
wonder if that was on purpose or not
yeah I was like you know it's curated it
has to be but I was like i joked about
with Cognito about his set I was like
man you warlock your new space Armada
shaman that literally reads verbatim
right there absolutely and we don't have
an activity called the room table and
Eris and live runes I'm like yeah that's
something new so I kind of wondered what
you guys thought about that do you think
she's just gonna have a kind of a vendor
a table sit next to her kind of like we
have with Osiris and you're making stuff
there or do you think it's gonna be
something more like public event type
thing where you actually have to go
crafted what we fight like a forge I
thought was it's probably gonna be a
variant of the chalice tum' to a certain
extent cuz I mean the rune table we're
using for sliding runes and the chalice
like my guess is that it'll just be some
sort of similar system to that I mean
obviously when I can be running
Menagerie for it
[Laughter]
he also teases some like unnamed
activity protected so it could be
something from that it could you could
earn rune sources from other places like
I don't know I mean I don't know forget
to still be hurting Menagerie runes on
top of I don't know honey runes but I
think they realized that everybody likes
the targeted farm so it's got to be some
variants of that whether like I don't
know if it'll just be for new sets or if
it'll be for a wider range of things but
that's my best guess is it's gonna be
something along those lines
yeah what about you yeah pretty much the
same thing I think definitely going down
at me you know ever um very curious to
see what redact is dying to know what
this activity is going to be you know
they've been on why I'm be a dungeon
outside of that I'm good I already know
what you're definitely have a dungeon no
I know they've said it I'm just way
before I'm kind of curious in the
preview because they
the rains gonna be on the black garden
so like the architecture it's not gonna
look the way the moon does but there's
this like spinning rotating spiny things
at one point yeah yeah I'm like is that
gonna be in the dungeon that's like a
hell jumping puzzle you gotta like weave
your way to something like an insta-kill
you is probably gonna be in the dungeon
yes absolutely
so hundred percent so as we go through
he does a kind of a brief touch back on
armor talking about it and this is one
thing I wanted to actually ask you guys
about just on my perspective as they
said when it comes to the original stats
that we've got mobility resilience and
discipline they know they're bringing in
inner thigh resilience my recovery and
mobility my bad knee too many words we
know the new ones are gonna be working
on recharge times and they're pretty
clear and they don't seem to be fully
linear but probably like diminishing
returns and stuff like that
but they did say they wanted to widen
the spread of the range with the old
stats and yet when they go through and
show resilience it's literally 1 percent
and that's probably about all we're
getting out of it right now cuz what's
the PvP health pool from like 186 to 202
or something depending on your
resilience level it's not much and
that's I guess this is the point where I
wonder when you get into and if they
want to go farther into an RPG if like
the stats that are probably gonna matter
more to everybody are gonna be the ones
that are related to abilities and
recharge times if the other ones don't
mean too much like if I don't move that
if I don't run any faster if my health
pool doesn't change that much more
recovery still is probably worthwhile
but if those two especially if you can't
move faster and you can't be tanked here
like my brother just wants to be a tank
yeah so if he could go like if he could
be like 100 resilience he would be happy
about it that he could be like I'm up
there in a Titan I'm punching stuff I've
got my Sentinel shield and if it drops
I'm still not gonna die I'm like one
squish maybe two what do you guys feel
do you guys look for do you guys think
they may be doing enough or do you think
that might not be there yet hmm for me I
get this hard even someone you care
about you know I do care about it I mean
especially mobility always had that
little issue with that I mean you know
scientist our speed is cool and all but
let's let's really go there with B let's
let's really take it there so you know
again the vibe I get from all of this is
in my opinion these are
precursor steps is a transitionary steps
to the eventual vision of d3 I don't
think we get these jarring things that
you may want initially from this I think
they're still in a touch-and-go let's
tweak let's see how the community
responds let's see how they like it
because I do think let's be on like
since they've gone independent this is
the first time they even mentioned
destiny in the same sentence with MMO so
now they're embracing it right so when
they embracing it I think it's just baby
steps let's let's play with it let's
tweak in if you know if you look at the
theme of Luke do all these directors
cuts he's telling you like hey we're
gonna see how this plays out and then
you you're gonna let us know what you
guys are gonna find things out and then
you guys are gonna let us know so I
think it's just part of the process man
and I think we do eventually get there
II I definitely do think we get there
too that that true MMO that true mid max
that all these hardcore sensibilities I
just think they want to do it in a very
controlled way that's just that's the
vibe I got what was you doing Paul yeah
I definitely gree with you I think it's
gonna be a very slow process I think
there will be at least some some measure
of changes like I don't know what's
exactly been confirmed but I thought
mobility might start to affect things
like sprint speed now and like the fraud
in that I don't know if that's the only
being put me on that but I mean if it
was gonna do anything you would think it
would do that so that's that needs a lot
of work because I remember running I was
running eaz my like green warlock billed
at zero mobility no stats and like it
wasn't great but like you barely really
noticed a difference like because it
doesn't affect that much um I think we
have a long way to get to you before we
get into like full MMO territory we're
like okay you have a Titan that Specht
fully resilience and you just can take
twice the damage of anything like him I
can see how that would be cool and that
would work but I just I can't imagine
that's gonna be something that were they
like flip switch and that's rightly how
things are now like I think it would be
cool to have like a tank spell caster
and a jumping melee person
going up hunter slash mix Ninja Assassin
and like I can see that happening it
just I feel like that's gotta be a slow
transition because if they if they try
and just massively change all these
stats upfront that may be really
disorienting and then you're gonna get
stuff like oh we're gonna have a six you
know Mac stack resilience raid team that
just just can't die so I think they got
to be careful with it but that said they
really do need to do that work because
those sets have just been so boring for
so long like the only one I really
notice on it gets this basis is Prager
you know because it's how you could
really see your Sheila coming back like
that much faster but resilience it's
always very nebulous and and mobility
you just don't notice that much so they
need work I just wonder how much of a
difference we're gonna see right off the
bat and shadow keep yeah II I mean I'm
you guys said everything I was thinking
and hoping for so that's I mean that's
where I'm at as I mean you look at
resilience as literally it's a one
person it seems like a very linear climb
it's one to ten percent it's like we
like do I move that one and you've got
mobility I think it was like four
percent still looking pretty great like
it was just straight but yeah it's like
this is strafing can't can't hit me in
it but it's like if I just go run down a
hallway next to you and you have ten and
I have zero where the same thing and
that should not mean that way that's
been so even if it is twenty percent
faster and that's one thing if they as
you said if they slowly get into that a
slow progression is what I would hope
for but I think the new stats are
probably going to be prioritized much
more than the others would be an
assumption because having their
abilities giving your Wells and those
types of things back faster it's
probably gonna serve people so your
problem gonna see probably a whole lot
of stacks of stat pools that people are
happy with when the bottom three are
pretty high and the times when people
don't care about it just saying there so
they have been telling a strength
discipline but there's there's nothing
that brings your class ability back no
faster right about that correct yeah I
wondered if they were gonna bring that
back when they talked about armor 2.0
cuz it'd be what a Paragon stat or
whatever they the mod yeah yes
yeah yeah so those are still yeah I
haven't quite dive too deep into those
things mmm and then the other piece we
get into as he kind of talks about goes
in a little bit about math and you got
the tears so it's gonna be really it's
if you can have your stats that ending
in a zero perfectly that's gonna be kind
of your god setup if you can get there
at least the most efficient version
everything Indian zero is gonna be
pretty important so then we get into the
armored migration and we talk about
going from everything we've been doing
for the past year which weekend would we
started to get perks and going into the
new system with the stats and I kind of
wanted to get your thoughts I was saying
this the kognito before you got on Paul
but I will say for me at least I think
this has actually been probably the most
generous way they could do it because
you could play with your old stuff for
as long as you want and you're gonna be
able to ease in as opposed to them just
drawing a line in the sand and be like
new season time to step over that line
so I think that's kind of nice how
they've handled that I just wondered if
you guys think there's you know any how
hard how long do you are you guys
playing in to hold on to your old gear
and stick with like hey I've got an
exotic car so furiosa with like double
sniper perks it's like well I'm gonna
live with that one for a while like do
you think do you think if they're not
gonna push people forward it's a bad
thing or do you think this is I guess
kind of the way they almost are forced
to do it the way people are so hold onto
their gear type yeah I think it's fine
people are giving me a lot of crap for
the article I wrote about like how it's
safe to delete all your armor oh yeah
basically is okay what I was saying like
I'm not mandating everyone because like
everything's gonna have pretty much
everything's gonna have an armor 3.0
source whether that's whether you find
that in two weeks or two months or
whatever but obviously if you have your
best PvE set or PvP set right now like
keep that and use that for as long as
you want I think this is a good way to
go about it
I personally am probably gonna start
transitioning into into 3.0 and pretty
quickly here because I imagine at least
your initial run-throughs of shadow keep
story content or aren't going to be like
crazy challenging activity so I kind of
rather just try out the new the new
armor that drop
the new mod systems and seeing what's
unlocked it depends how fast we could
start unlocking things like I know I'm
not gonna have like enhanced everything
in week one but I also don't think I
need enhanced everything in week one
like you know if it comes to like
running the raid or something or if
there's like iron banner and I want to
get like really serious about it and
yeah I'll probably stick with my like
totally tricked-out stuff that I have
now because that will still be perfectly
functional but I personally I'm playing
so much I'm gonna get a lot of stuff
pretty directly I imagine and like I
have all these my components saved up
then like I have upgrade materials so I
see no reason why I can't start shifting
into things pretty quickly but it's good
that they're not just like everything
you have is now useless yeah it does
lock word because you have now your one
armor with no perk your two armor with
perks and consumable mods and then your
armor with permanent mods and like all
those systems are still technically
staying in place so his it's a little
convoluted and it's it's kind of weird
it's gonna be a transition to kind of
phase everything to 2.0 and you probably
will end up deleting all your year one
and your tiara stuff eventually but for
a while it's gonna be a little it's even
weird that we have like consumable gun
mod still and not consumable harbor bots
yeah it's it's kind of an awkward
transition phase but I think that's what
it is I think transition phase so it's
kind of to be expected yeah I mean
listen until I get my mouth was it my
light reactor but the Lunik linear
faction a little bit of fusion scavenger
you know there's certain things I gonna
love it I for certain activities I have
a specific spec and and literally per
subclass and per activity in PvP so it's
gonna be harder for a guy like me that
holds on to those things to let them go
but eventually it will happen you're
gonna get stuff unlocked you're gonna
slowly progress and I'm gonna have to
let go my little motional attachment but
in a beginning for pinnacle stuff I'm
gonna be playing some of my art bills
I'm not gonna like like you know so
shadow shout the horse he doesn't he was
in a chat you saying that um he was
asking if the old armor can be infused
and I was pretty sure Luke said
the you know things yeah so yeah you're
not too worried about that
RT 86 but um yeah man I mean that's how
I'm going at it I I think it's gonna
come down to my orangie how good is rng
gonna be good to me
during the first you know the campaign
of shadow keep and as we progress
because if you if we get a lot of this
stuff pretty early then yeah we're gonna
be throwing the old stuff you know away
fairly quickly and then having that
ability to just really you know
customize even more so how are you gonna
handle it mister are you gonna do II I'm
curious I've got a day scheduled in late
September for a vault plead out yes
obedia only I'll behave out ASMR by
pontus that's how that's gonna be no
seriously cuz I've been I mean I've got
a little bit of everything in a trained
specialist cuz I mean if I get say a
pair of gauntlets that's like grenade
launcher loader and gun a launcher
scavenger I'm like that's pretty damn
specialized than those often for my
tight and I'm like I'm keeping that so
throw I gotta say yeah I got like some
referee dawn joint with you sniper
reload US sniper scavenger like that's I
got a whisper and a Darcy build just for
that like it's gonna be hard until I get
that stuff back continue yeah I mean
those types of things I know I'll go
through and keep but I'll definitely be
more generous and be like oh this is
kind of yeah those are normal buy it
like in hint stuff I might keep if it's
like kind of a perfect roll but most of
my stuff is gonna be cleaned out I will
say I'll probably keep a lot of my
webshop and options because we still
don't know what the sandbox is gonna do
until we get our hands on it but most of
my vault is more armored than weapons so
I'm pretty excited about that but I do
think I mean they're being again as you
said there's three different versions of
armor technically we have which is just
kind of weird but they haven't ever
drawn a line in the sand and they're
being fairly nice they're player base
because if you go into I don't know any
other expansion or anything like that
you get a new piece of armor you we this
is the only game i can honestly think of
where we've continued to bring stuff
forward where we have fuse things up
because world of work I have to get a
new expansion goodbye amazing armor my
new blues at 71 versus signaling instead
of 70 are so much better so they haven't
made us do that yet and I hope as they
kind of get closer and closer to the RPG
vibe that they do eventually get to that
level it's amazing because it is nice
just that's one of the times that this
game feels the best is when we're
leveling up or experiencing new content
were not just trying to keep towing this
giant like trailer of stuff behind us
that we want to keep using we just want
to get to the new stuff and have some
fun with that so I'm hoping eventually
get they get there but they are being
very nice to the player base right now
letting you ease in as slowly as you
like so that's actually pretty cool cool
he goes through kind of a live journal
thing talking about some stuff but the
big stuff to talk about will be the
pursuit of power and he talking about
this actually in part one as well
basically stating we've got so many
things on the director I'm if you boot
it up right now and you log in be like
hey it's Tuesday at 12:01 dear god
there's a lot to do row I mean and it's
not a bad thing to say hey there's a lot
of stuff to do in the game
there's nothing but I think what really
brought everything to the head and
probably has made people realize it was
the the pictures and the spreadsheets
for the season of opulence raid great
cuz in six hours you're trying to figure
out what am I gonna have to do and you
look through and you're like oh my god
so I gotta go to do the dreaming city
mission do shadow throne maybe just the
first encounter go do wheelie counters
bounties and all those things and it's
it's a lot and if you have like for the
new light players I'm really glad
they're kind of getting a piecemeal like
slowly add planets over time so they
don't get overwhelmed hmm
but we've got the idea they basically
are at is there's too many places for
power and none of it really means that
much so they're gonna work on curating
that a little bit and we've got kind of
a difference in the way primaries are
gonna work world drops are gonna work
and then also kind of pinnacles and
things so first we've got an idea where
our light levels going so we're making a
pretty big leap with up to 950 +
question mark cuz we've got but I'm
wondering I was saying it might be a
thousand because you've got soft cap
sounds like about 900 we're pretty much
anything will level you up they said
Prime Minister once you had the number
you have you will get more priming grams
in a week but they said they're gonna
rebalance the value so they probably
won't be five or six
they'll probably be a little lighter but
they did also say world drops are going
to be kind of giving you a boost if you
have a power level of 912 you got some
big drops and you got this one straggler
back there you can get a random
legendary that can finally help you and
that's yeah that's a great idea yeah
that's good that's really good mmm so
that's a quality of life piece big-time
and then we get into so that's kind of
just the power the way it's all coming
in and I wanted to ask you guys they say
like short term goal can a weekly
medium-term goal like what are you guys
how long do you think for one as we kind
of have numbers to work with like 900
950 where do you think the raids gonna
let stand at about four days with
contests so that's first one so let's go
there what do you guys think that raid
light levels gonna be cuz contest is
gonna be on so it's not gonna matter if
you get above it but where do you think
they're gonna set it if we're getting up
to 950 plus ish mmm Paul what you dig
Matt I generally don't know oh it's such
a big big jump I tried to remember the
last time we had well for say Shawn was
probably like 220 course taking was like
two 20 minutes yeah I don't even know if
I can pinpoint it cuz like then what
happens when you're like you know super
over level I'm guessing they might just
do the prestige it's just higher and I
don't know yeah I just I just know that
they're gonna put those world's first
rules but I assume they gonna put those
world's first rules back in you know at
certain points of known count as will be
there yeah a contest is definitely gonna
beat it but um yeah I don't know but
it's such a jump this is Henry starting
off sir and then we go all we go wait
wait I'm not we're not ready for like
talking and getting there getting there
okay so everyone over the floor is 750
mm how I mean how far can you possibly
get in how many days is it four days
days when Friday five days I guess but
yeah so judge judging by like current
stuff you can jump maybe like what 20
2013 4 lucky you get up that high and
like a with your initial natural sources
so it's got to be within that
range like within 50 but then there's
200 more yeah like so it's like what
yeah I'm really it's gonna be weird of
the rates like 800 or whatever but then
there's like some other pinnacle it's
like 950 later when you see there would
be because right there's got to be
something up that high or else there's
no point in the next 200 yeah I don't
know we were so used to these little
like 50 jumps that we don't really mMmmm
we had a big one was forsaken wearable
382 600 so that oh what's that okay yeah
so that was the biggest one and thinks
the Solstice of Heroes got you what does
it get you to 400 if you grind it on the
arm or something so I mean that's still
200 points but we had 10 days we had a
longer time before shorter window what
is the weather it's what was the ridge
starting at 565 540 but by the time you
got to the end it was like 570 something
right I know it was up there okay so I
mean you're talking at least 150 points
that people climbed but that was over 10
days of grinding and now we have four mm
I know somewhere between 800 850 yes but
but also just wonder it's like what
that's gonna do to as you said what is
the future grind like what's the reason
to get above if the rate is 800 do they
do heroic rate at 900 I mean it's that's
what's that they have to almost do a
heroic if they're gonna do it that fast
yeah a concern because once once that
initial raid week in world's first is
over what we achieved these light levels
then we're gonna start squashing that
thing and I mean so it's just like I am
concerned with long play ha - Hannah do
we get the return of the heroic modes
and stuff like that you know it
challenge moans damn yeah it's
interesting many I don't envy them with
this design but I wouldn't want to be
them with this this is really you know
interesting you know a choices they have
to make hold on one second yeah go for
it man what oh yeah I don't know man
850 maybe you know yeah I'm let's see
him more days along but I could see that
yeah baby break it on also break it down
by a count I think Cali
she was like a checkpoint at a certain
light level and then maybe I don't we
got to see then with the world's first
mechanics on top of that there's a lot
of it's getting complicated it's getting
complicated very good oh yeah I'm good
sorry just in the route in my throat oh
good so we've got I mean you kind of
touched on but new light is coming and
that's gonna bring a lot of players in
and they were just saying hey what do
these players gonna come in at they
don't wanna come in at level ten and be
like hey you're gonna go grind out like
how are you like a thousand hours well
I'm never gonna do that and so everybody
who comes in a new light starts a 750
but guess what if you have like an alt
that's like 310 right now
make sure it's wearing something because
it's gonna be 750 as well every single
yeah you don't have to get some
achievements on xbox thank you yeah I
just like literally log into character
hello max that's a good point I gotta
tell so my friends that lack of achieve
X box with the full across play glows
lab next week oh yeah I gotta grab this
new light when we finish so yeah new
lights gonna be an awesome thing for one
I think steam is gonna be huge we've
talked about that before but I mean you
you played enough games you know the
Steam player base is massive so a free
game at this scale to be well a free
game to be like hey here's destiny two
year one with these proper systems in it
they're jumping in it like the perfect
place they couldn't possibly be but yeah
everything everything in your toy alt is
gonna be infused so the first thing he
said stop spending currency which they
told me that like a month ago hey this
guy who's been not spending currency
you're fine I'm the biggest offender
yeah yeah like oh this looks pretty
infuse this looks pretty huge but it's
like how I get when I get a god man that
thing's getting 10 cores easy like
that's just how I am bro like I go
shimmery box I need my dogs to come out
like the same primary too long my go
figure is your go figure I have like
40,000 kills with that thing though so I
love it no Yogo figures a beast don't
get me wrong I get it
what should go figural uh it's bad as
like perfect as I can go for Holden let
me click on it it's got outlaw rampage
and then long zoom scope with range
master work you know and stock on it so
the aim assist literally sits perfect or
the recoil Direction is it goes from 69
to 85 so thanks to fall it's a little
new sine graph video strike fall out
what else great it's dead on so when I
go pick up any other pulse rifle it
doesn't nothing feels as good impulses
wait so the pulse rifle nerves
oh my god I was hoping maybe get to like
77,000 kills if I got to keep using it
just to send that picture to Bungie but
no at some point it's going away but
honestly also I think I totally skipped
over at some point scout rifles getting
a buff by the way it was gold relation
just chillin waiting waiting for this
buff man yeah it'll be good so you want
to fire buff that's what I want for
Scouts yeah yeah yeah I want Alerus
Lance told man I was alive that couldn't
be powerful with above but um like cuz I
got chomped yeah I'm talking about so I
mean it's kind of where at so you had
something so go for it yeah I mean this
was interesting because it was a I had a
duel feeling like I was I was conflicted
initially because the hardcore destiny
playing me is like I work for this stuff
you gonna let these guys who's come in
here I was a little motion I admit you
know say but then I thought about it and
Luke made a great point one of the worst
feelings like we're all door everyone
here and last we're the hardcore right
so what sucks is there I have friends
that generally do like pay attention to
what's going on with destiny and they
wanna get and the worst feeling is like
alright bro we're gonna start up and
then all your light level is there
alright so you go over there and you
grind out all this stuff did you get
back to me and then we never play like
we never play together so again I do
like this because it's like okay day one
everyone's gonna get two rocks with each
other we have cross save going on it's I
think it's critical for them the
question I have for you too though
is now that they implement this right
do we think cease after season of the
undying season after whatever is this
going to be a thing that or is it going
to be something that is just gonna be
like power surge again afterwards you
know saying power surge brownies again
at that that's my question to you guys
because I do like this man I I know I
probably don't know if how the community
feels overall with with new light and
everyone getting that level but it just
sucks to separate your friends because
they are just not at your level based on
your level of commitment look what you
guys do I think this is just operating
it's kind of a hard reset just to get
everyone on the same page for new light
when it's free-to-play so people don't
show up and already feel behind great I
do not think that they're gonna do this
exact thing every season my guess is
that we return to some sort of power
surge bounty system they almost have to
because one of the new things are doing
is that you can skip seasons and then
just buy a new season later correct so
if you buy if you skip the next season
and the buy the season after then you're
gonna be like a hundred power behind but
complain if there's power surge bounties
to take you up to like ten below the
minimum or 20 below or whatever it is
then that's not a problem but if you
don't have that then you're gonna run
into all those same problems again so I
don't think they're gonna take everybody
to max letting the old max every single
season because I think that would get
annoying and then I would just everyone
would just stop grinding a certain point
he's like what you're getting close to
the end to the season stop y'all stuff
yeah like 20 the end and you're not
really getting it for anything just
whatever but so I don't think that's
like a permanent addition that seems
kind of like a one-time thing they're
just gonna do pretty light laughing I
think I think I think you're on it
I mean all in all yeah I mean I think
the the question comes into the next
point as well what they're gonna do with
the seasonal artifact because they have
the bonus in there and I'm wondering as
that resets is that how they I'll just
jump into its Kurt this is this is this
is a good one so okay we've got the
potential source saying like hey like
950 is
gonna be kind of a hard power cap and
then above that you're gonna be able to
earn higher power by pinnacle activities
so pinnacle activities were wondering
okay so if you do raids you do dungeons
you do iron banner
I wish iron banner wasn't in there but
that's me in a different argument easy
easy easy
there's a difference of like trying to
actually beat a raid or a dungeon or
even competitive oh here we go
slander jail but you can finish nice you
can do the minimal activities whatever
they qualify those to be and get above
950 but that's the only way you're gonna
be able to do it but they also describe
the seasonal artifact as a way to kind
of put experience into it and level up
over time so these are the two questions
I think we barely touched on it before
will these two stack on top of each
other is there gonna be like an ultra
cap as we're joking like hey a thousand
is it now you can do the pinnacles and
you can grind it faster and get there or
do you spin the whole season with the
seasonal artifact and experience to just
spend strikes and basic crucible to get
up to that cap or do they double and you
can get up to 1050 if you're like
pinnacle and seasonal crazytown and then
the question would be is if you can get
to say shadow keep and its rate as this
and then you get to a thousand and you
get to 1050 again question don't know if
you reset it is that how they're gonna
do the season rotation and then keep
everybody even or are you gonna keep
stacking on afterwards so this is the
whole power level discussion I wanted to
get in with you guys cuz there's a lot
of levels to this get a poet is an
article right here go there's about four
questions right here I can barely
comprehend how the artifacts even work
that to me is one of the most confusing
points for this I don't think we have
any of this confirmed but like the way I
would imagine it working is that it's
both because if you're I can't imagine
you would have to choose between like
doing pinnacle activities and doing the
artifact right although if you're doing
pinnacle activities you're probably also
getting experience to level up the
artifact at the same time so the way I
think it would work is like okay just
the cap is a thousand let's just assume
it doesn't go over a thousand from 950
to a thousand if you were doing pinnacle
activities you're getting
Arkel drops and you're leveling it up at
a decent clip on top of whatever slope
our bonuses you're getting for the
seasonal artifact I think maybe you can
just grind the seasonal artifact and if
you're not doing clinical activities you
can maybe still hit the cap mm-hmm but
you're also two things you're also
you're getting they're a lot slower
because you're not getting any bonus
powerful drops so it might take you
literally the whole season of just
grinding regular crucible or strikes or
whatever you want to do to get there but
you can still get there right and if
this is a temporary bonus if we get to
the next season and then suddenly the
cap is like eleven hundred pinnacle
people may stay at the cap whereas
you're then knocked down to 950 see
underground art okay and then have to
start getting blues or whatever like
more basic stuff to get back up again
I don't again I don't know that's how
it's gonna work but they are talking
about this power bonus across your
characters being temporary also well I
guess one other thing that the artifact
is that it's it's it's cross character
whereas pinnacle grinding is is on each
of your individual characters so I think
it's it's gotta be real it's gotta be a
really slow crowd I think it was like
what they were showing was like fifty
five thousand experience for maybe one
PowerPoint mm-hmm which is slow what's
our experience Bart now I don't even
remember what it is I don't know either
but I know like a public event is you
two or three thousand or something it's
it's work crucible match gives you like
forty five hundred or something like
that so it's it's it would be a lot of
grinding of just like normal activities
but I don't understand very many things
about the artifacts still so I don't
Evan is super correct answer no I think
that's a good hold on cognate oh you're
what can you hear me no no all right
back okay cool yeah like um I think
that's a good assumption
um Paul are they I think that they can
definitely work it like that
um the list of vibe I got from it like I
know people shot my boy comm box I know
he will never do pinnacle you'll never
catch him in the raid
you don't say he just wants to operate
at his pace and things he likes to do
and I think this cuz again if you talked
about their design philosophy with d2
and they kind of almost went too casual
you know I'm saying I think this is to
appease to that group that is never
really gonna do that but they can still
find a way a progression and also reward
the guy that's kind of playing every day
that may get unlucky sometimes you know
I'm saying I think that's the vibe I'm
getting from artifacts a little bit um I
do like the fact that pinnacle you know
activities are going to be that source
that faster sort I really like that I
hate to get bougie but like that's how
we gotta be but if I'm doing the hardest
activities
I should be reward that should be and
lets me really like the problem that
they have with the powerful it just it
was just way too many like you literally
did not have to do the raid you didn't
have that you can sit there and live on
a dreaming city you can sit there and
live in one specific DLC and you can
power grind and I think that was hurting
them you know as far as the difficulty
as well so from a design standpoint I
get it
you got eliminate a lot of this all
these you know challenging powerful
engrams all over the map I'm with that
but I love the fact of getting back to
OD one well if you want to get to that
max light you got to do the raid you got
to do you know whatever that pinnacle
activities I love that stuff and in like
he said Luke said you know destiny to me
has meaning when you walk in the tower
and you see someone back back in the day
with that trial set and you saw someone
with that full race anyway yo you know
that's how he's got that level of power
and you know that's the activity I want
to grind for and that's what I want you
know I think the biggest mistake d2 made
was just like everyone gets raid gear go
to Hawthorn yeah yeah like that pissed
me off in the worst way and I hate it to
sound bougie because at the time
deafening to was selling well I was
disgusted Paul I gotta be I was asked I
was people in my clan that didn't step
foot in the rain and they run around
with midnight cool oh oh you know sins
of the past and I'm like I'm doing it I
don't even have
oh man so I don't know motional right
now but we got it is levels to this we
got a VIP some things here we got a
reward the hard court quite Timmy's I
personally love it I'm curious to see
you know back to the original question
with um artifacts how it's gonna go but
the vibe I got is that it's gonna reward
that guy who's not gonna do that other
stuff and still be able to maybe you
know slowly keep up he's you have to
play a lot but you know at least you can
kind of maintain eat wait where's your
whole thing with this but I'm curious
very chairs about you when artifacts
were you know introduced you know how do
you feel about so yeah the artifact is a
weird thing and again like if the hard
firm max is 1000 he's you're saying it's
faster slower you get there it kind of
makes sense it's kind of a similar thing
I was thinking cuz if you stack above
that it's probably too big a disparity
between maybe a slower casual player who
doesn't do raids versus somebody who
does all the things they're almost like
getting up to 100 points in difference
mm-hmm that's a pretty big disparity 50
power points I could see and then if
you're a little slower on the grind you
might end up at like 970 I do kind of
like the idea of the reset that maybe
hey my gear sits at like 9 75 and then
I've got a bonus of the artifact to get
me to that final thousand I'm 25 points
ahead of you in that next season starts
so that grinds a little different so
what Paul said that's actually a really
good idea I mean for me I'm the same way
I'm the crazy person who solo challenges
myself on a bunch of stuff so I mean
doing the hard content and getting
rewarded for it yes absolutely cuz
honestly I think one thing the game has
been lacking since the 1 is the need for
the raid there is a reason people
there's a reason forever 29 was a thing
is because so many people were actually
rating at that time and I know it was
still a small number that did but there
was incentive to do it because that's
how you maxed out do you want that
number to be the max it can be yep why
or how do you get there well I got to
find some way to do it LF G's were
probably more popular and things like
that because you had more people doing
it maybe I just had a good group of
friends that did want to but even then
they wanted to and now it's just my
issue with iron banner and I'll say this
iron banner I do enjoy the mode I like
it always feels a little bit different
the power level seems to just I don't
know it just always feels a little
different in PvP but it's still it's
still a way for someone to
fail forward Rankin's suck in pvp and
still get like pinnacle level gear and
there's no there's not a lot of skill
behind that and that's one of those
things where you take away from as he's
saying it's like you know you look at
somebody who's 960 and they did a bunch
of pinnacle activities or did they just
wait for iron banner to come around and
the pinnacle people might be ahead of
them but that was the issue that started
in d1 is d1 started with being able to
level you up in iron banner and it's
been a continuation of where everything
does it now and I I mean I like the
mentality of getting back more to this
and I know iron banners only come up
once a month so it's not like you can
just be like oh stop this man is landing
bro I'm feeling way rock
I like the mode is out here every week
now come on babe let's feel it feels
more recent but anyway you have seven
bounties in a quest that's 12 powerful
drops and without trials I know
something I know I know I know
yes Landrum always comes back yeah I
know it's not that often it's just one
of those that it's kind of that little
boot that's a little boost and often it
be active in matches so I do generally
like the idea of pinnacle activities
rewarding above and if you get to 950
and you're like how do I get to 951
you're like I gotta go do that and it's
but that's the point where some people
might be like alright I'm setting aside
some time we're gonna try and do this
and hopefully more people will want to
we just got to see if it's gonna be
worth the difference but I'm kind of
hoping it is so I like what they're
doing I like the again the artifact is a
huge question mark in this whole
equation because we don't have a clue
how it works how the modifiers aren't
the mods on it are gonna work what you
buy and this bonus thing is gonna be a
grind so there's a lot of pieces of this
we don't know it's a bigger power cap
than I expected to be honestly because
they were showing 800 on streams looks
like is it gonna be like eight 850 we're
like 950 to a thousand and this is just
shadowing wave season so yeah it will be
talking next year about this time it
will be like 1500 power level it's fine
and then the final piece they said they
have tried to learn their lesson from
cores and master works and we'll see I
mean they say they don't want it to be
Feynman but we've got enhancement prisms
and ascendant shards
I kept calling I was in my little
streams and I was looking at the
ascenders how it looks like a exotic
golf ball but that's holding that's what
it looks like it's got simples on it so
but those are gonna be kind of a big
piece for leveling up your armor mm-hmm
but that kind of actually covers some of
the big stuff anything from the
directors cuts but you guys can think of
that I haven't touched on keep talking
and we'll just do a live review with
Paul and you can write your own we go
we'll give you feedback you know
normally when we have guests on we do
kind of get just a little bit but I
wanted to kind of in in your proper
spirit and fashion the top five destiny
moments for your experience in the
franchise no pressure man no pressure
let's go let's get it for you normal
it's like normally it's the top things
you knew so what would be your top five
moments from I can't do these in order
no no it's just big ones yeah just as
they come to me my I'm the most proud
probably of my 24-hour reckless grind
that was my 115 cat games in a row
like I don't know where nice Wow to do
it I had a lot of fun when M dash
carried me to flawless trials I was one
time I mean first fall to class
sail again would you check our cast is a
lot of volt a grassland a pool and I'm
out here fighting the good fight and
fight the good fight and tell him why in
the boat class well if we agree on what
under why like I will okay what are you
okay I'll get you another question after
this yeah but his well I'm not even like
a big raider like I don't even rate as
much as his most hardcore people it's
just that first of all the best
experience was unlike anything else kind
of in in games that we never really come
across something like that and it in a
shooter before it's all Jeff AC fix your
face
in a battle like you know MMO things so
it just wasn't anything anyone really
expected like I wasn't doing it on like
day one and like dying over and over
again it was just the first time I
experienced it was was pretty fantastic
um man it was like a specific drop that
just like lit me up cuz like I never got
my gal her and drop I had to buy it the
second time and we gallon
yeah whisperer that was that was really
solid that was up there I was like
that's my me whisper an outbreak that
might be the same thing but like any any
dungeon you experience for the first
time is stellar did you have you like
solo cheddar thrown on that stuff or no
I'm not that hardcore
like I'm like I'm like a 90% level
hardcore like I'm not like only a
thousand hours or whatever yeah like
three to four so like I'm I'm more I'm
like hardcore casual we're like I play a
ton but I'm not like only running
clinical stuff over and over again yeah
shadow throne itself is is definitely
kind of a top moment in and of itself
just I did try and solo it like the
first time through just to see how far I
could get and I got to the ogre and that
was a rushed night there how many times
there's crazy yeah that was that was a
cool experience I don't know I probably
can come up with like a full top ten
list so I just have to think think back
a little more but those are probably
there's another article thirty just like
what's before shadow key yeah yeah no I
I'm sure there's more I'm forgetting and
like there's been so much cool loot to
use and good experiences and okay okay I
got a do this top three ready all you
really gonna do it now top three raids
he's really ghost he's starting trouble
right now he's pushing buttons right now
say number one is last wish
respect I respect it number two probably
vault of glass
it's just nostalgia 3 I don't know I a
lot of people in Leviathan last but I
personally like the lie really pounding
the I'm kind of lumping in all the
layers to like I just think that was
like a good good zone good experience I
use man apartment to be in this and yeah
looks like I haven't done scourge of the
past like I yeah like its I just gift
some random way to in there so I don't
know played like a fully comprehensive
but I I think it's hard to top west
which I just think that was next level
on every level so I mean then that's I
mean yeah we usually we give each other
crap but our top three generally are
whichever order you put them in the
vault of glass last wish and Kings fall
see Kings fall is probably to over both
the glass yeah those are the only if you
say Kings fallen last wish together in
my mind is they're both the mansion oh
yeah but you know why I respect portal
yeah
through last wish in it and I'll just
give me your reason as to why it's the
ultimate or the same thing you would say
so yeah oh legend yeah personally I just
like I more like a conceptual story
person so it for me it's like the
environment and how it relates to the
lore and like some of the mechanics I'm
like iffy on like shooting the eyes it's
okay but for me it's just the whole the
whole environment the whole relation to
the story and the how it tied into the
dreaming city and then you get in and
unlock stuff after like that's that's
why what I want raids to be is stuff
that affects the broader world and it's
not just this like tiny little locked
away bit of content and I think we're
seeing that like you know we had a whole
expansion based on Calais who's a raid
boss which you never seen before
essentially so
I like stuff that kind of spans the
whole life lifetime and destiny preach
it brother
preach it man I mean that literally I
mean II you were there right when I was
talking to or was our a lead yeah I
literally said that I said that's what
separates last wish narrative lis you
know you do the campaign it leads to the
dream of city dreamin see that it goes
into that and it is just the matter it
fits so perfect as opposed to hey just
go random encounter and fight big bad
you know without any context without any
narrative progression and connectivity
towards it and I still think like one of
the greatest things even when you beat
Riven just leaving and escaping with the
heart is so cool shout out to that music
I forgot the components you know that
gets me pumped man you know I think the
same thing they use when yes sure no Chi
fight but man yeah I completely agree I
think if anyone says I'm involved with
that family whatever anyone says last
wish or Kings fall his King Falls I feel
like a I'm andreas rage rate you know
they you know kind of thing with the
bosses and stuff and I respect somebody
yeah but I got a slanted gaming forum
for how Dan they have rapid machine no
over fourth to class we're gonna talk
about yeah I mean somehow we've had the
craziest week but we knocked everything
out basically we've got an hour until
part three goes live and that one is
actually going to be covering a couple
things I know you guys are waiting on
when it comes to combat in PvP
especially so I wanted to ask when it
comes to PvP what are you hoping for
with shadow key mmm they got at you they
got to make some heavy changes I think
nerfing Guardi damage I machine gun is
good so you're not just like two tapping
everybody for like a forty round clip or
whatever you get from heavy PvP specific
kind of eternal supers are problem based
on the map or how fast you can generate
supers now so you have getting killed
twice by the same super in one life and
I hate that wild
like it feels like you lacks you into
like pretty much only these roaming
supers and milk in most PPP modes those
I think are kind of the two biggest
things but I'm hoping whatever nerfs go
into play there they're not anything
that affects PvE
because you never know like I don't want
them to like super regeneration but PvP
needs kind of a different toolkit so
those to me are the two biggest issues
I'd also like to see kind of more a more
wider variety of map design like I don't
know how many maps are getting with with
shadow key but to me like part of the
reasons like scout rifles are bad is
because there's many maps that are even
good for them yeah things like that so I
think more map diversity will also
hopeful things too yeah and I don't
think they're going to talk about trials
I'm not even trust being guy yeah put
that emotional part aside I like sorry
coming but um yeah I mean poor you
knocked it out I mean pretty much the
same boat I mean we definitely got to
get some rebalancing in the meta we
Scout sin and in there we got that going
roman supers a bit egregious um you know
just more arm flexibility with moulds as
opposed to everything lumped up into
quick play and you know I'm saying I
kind of mess supremacy a little bit as
well you know I mean um this it's not a
bunch of things I think maps are huge I
mean we've got so many d1 maps that
could be repurposed that were designed
for 6v6
good I mean that we really need to come
back you know man I'm dying to know you
know and I can our into what is those be
my requests and if they happen to say
that they're thinking about bringing
Trials back at some point trials of
osiris Neptune I'm we want the nice
Egyptian armor we want Osiris and all
his glory we needed we need to redeem
him for that terrible DLC but anyway but
yeah seriously I mean I don't expect it
it would be nice but I think that's in
the future but as long as PvP modes Maps
meta FASTA meta turnaround - that would
be nice you know just you know there's a
lot of things I think they said they're
just gonna keep sticking with like you
know I mean you know not great I'm not
having that baby I'll let you finish it
off with the PvP your favorite mode
no I mean for my banner yeah continue
I played 136 matches of iron banner
thank you very much recently saluted you
got you got you about Civic well I know
because I counted because that's
literally all I did that week and I was
like and I actually pulled Blake what
map I played I was very curious about
the stats on it and actually I'm a
pretty decent map distribution I was
surprised curious how many wins and
losses I had no I was grinding for
mountaintop I was doing the dam in
pursuit of honor
so I was just living with grenade
launchers in there so that's why it was
now it's gonna be nerfed so yeah I mean
that's coming in September but that's
fine it's done so mm-hmm
yeah just in time for it to get nerfed
ooh for me I'm with you guys it's the
I'd like to see competitive as I've
actually been spending more time in
there get a little bit more just a
little bit more love a little more it
needs to be a real mode I'd like to see
them do I don't know if they can yet I
mean I don't see dedicated servers I see
that is like d3 same thing with like
cross play and those type of bigger like
deep net code system changes like that
stuff I don't think happening but I mean
if they can put like a ladder system in
or different rankings involved and you
know some type of depth though people
want even if it's not like the trials
yet they think that's where they need to
start so then I was gonna have something
else but it needs to have depth to it
because even me I know I'm not gonna be
in like legend hating 5500 for me is
unlikely to happen especially solo
queueing but hmm
I'd like to see a reason I like that
incentive for me to be like hey I got a
little bit of glory but are there the
latter systems and things like that and
I think the population influx from new
light is gonna help them hopefully be
able to be like if they take the bet
that saying hey we're gonna go a lot of
new players in here as you said get more
playlists are we gonna have rift are we
gonna have supremacy are we gonna
actually have a choice of control or
clash when I go to the Draenor to choose
what I want to play and I think they've
been worried about their player bases
maybe one reason they haven't split it
up yet so I'm just so new light makes
quick play less sweaty yeah bunch of new
people freeing there's more sweaty than
competitive now I don't know why I'm
with you I just played like the last
couple I've been working on just random
stuff in there too but it wasn't even
comp it's just quick play for matches of
link I'm like working hard what is the
pudding right now like even
neck-and-neck
working on a comeback I'm like this is
quick play right even an iron banner is
easier than quick play now because if
you're max level you're at least
fighting some people that are playing
level so your kid you can advantage from
that so it's your system right now but
agree oh good yeah so sadly I don't see
dedicated servers which just want to
know everyone would love yeah we know
we've been creaming that for a long time
but yeah that's deep yeah that's later
so yeah those are my big ones just a
little more depth in comp so I've got a
reason a little more player choice of
what I want to play play I was checking
Twitter to see if the thing went by
early like we would just go through it
but ya know they've been dropping right
at about noon it was even yesterday I
was like an 12:05 refresh OOP there it
is so oh yeah I'm down here in Texas so
we got the this side of the u.s. covered
well man this has been awesome I wanted
to respect your time so we're holding
right at just about two hours
oh yeah perfect I gotta go let my dog
out it's lunch before this we look out
for that article man yeah so I wanted to
just thank you for coming in it was
awesome to meet you and definitely I
appreciate having you on obviously keep
doing everything awesome that you were
doing cuz always a quick read even just
no matter I'm too and it's like all
Paul's got an article it's like what's
he got to say it's like and we're all
pretty in tune to it but it's like I
always like seeing your opinion because
it's well said and fair and I appreciate
that I think yours is always correct
thank you I mean the biggest thing is
you're fair you're gonna call a spade a
spade you're gonna say hey this is good
hey this is not and need some help but
you're gonna do it in a you know
professional respectful way so yeah if
you guys want to know how to give
constructive criticism go read his stuff
absolutely the best way to do it thank
you absolutely one of the best one of
the very very best honor to have here
and like I said just very clear concise
and you don't say always Oh like I said
just passion that what I like about you
just passionate for the Luna shooter
genre as well that's knee once you
definitely your favorite gallery yeah
let's go
çb saying always order I was compiling
heat like destiny I'm bias let's go with
Joe Doakes is one of the very best when
your articles always put a notification
on first to read and see what's going on
see what your thought process is keep up
the fantastic work I'm gonna have you
here man this is awesome definitely
something I really appreciated oh thanks
so much right man this is a great show
I'd be happy to be back
whatever anytime anytime by the campfire
buddy I'm glad you like the name - I saw
your little tweet yeah there's a couple
reasons but ya know so we do try we use
this may sound like it's kind of stolen
but as it is literally we try and get in
the last word so what I'm trying to say
like kind of implode wrap-up at
everything and then we say this has been
the last word and that's where we cut
the episode getting there I'm getting
there
so I'm just letting them know like when
we get to like final wrap-up so but yeah
let me just tell everybody where they
can find you what you doing what you got
cooking anything coming up so anybody on
audio YouTube twitch wherever they're
seeing you so they can find you more and
about the novels me yeah good now let's
get the full plug all right full plug so
I am just on Twitter at Paul Tassie I am
on Twitter probably the most set of
anything and tweeting way too much
probably 80% of my tweets are about
destiny so you know follow me there if
you want to read my Forbes stuff there
was links on Twitter that I post every
day I post on my articles you can I
don't even know my site URL just google
my name just Google policy and it'll
show up this is the first thing it's not
a very not a very common name and then
yeah in my first time I do like to try
and write books I have a science fiction
trilogy called the Earthborn trilogy
that's been out for a couple years now
and then I have my book that came out
last about a year ago it's called hero
killer it's like a near-future
sci-fi gladiator story and then I just
finished writing cure killer - um so now
have to just edit it and see talk to my
publisher see if I might self publish
this time it's cheaper
finally and we'll see what happens with
that but that that might take a couple a
couple more months or whatever to get
out but yeah for books if you want to
you only get through those and let me
know what you think I'd be happy to hear
about it absolutely awesome mm-hmm
absolutely man salute man and also some
fantastic Walking Dead takes I love your
walk in there Jake oh yeah fear fear
fears right now but then Walking Dead
proper comes back I'll be watching that
show till the end of times three or four
episodes into the boys right now by the
way great things that is a hell of a
take on that genre just to be like take
everything you think in the moral and
just flip it and it's yeah oh man it's
been it was on Amazon they're actually
using so they like Joe and I was up they
have my quote that's one of the reasons
I checked it out because I had seen one
belief brief thing and that's how you
say it knows like kind of check it out
so yeah I watched it twice right i watch
it once by myself then once with my wife
my wife and i are for for him so we're
working through it but yeah thank you
for that recommendation it's fun stuff
coming as you know I don't know if it
was you or somebody was like no in the
first episode yep they went there and I
was just like oh my god they did like it
did not take long in that first episode
at all that's true yeah Cognito well if
you want to wrap up yours Lord cockney
know on Twitter you too before all that
again Paul Tassie thank you so much for
coming this really means a lot to us to
have you here like I said you have no
idea this is a fantastic show always
great to hear it takes so that's off the
back but you know on Twitter Lord
cockney or no Adler neato and of course
I love podcasts YouTube every Sunday is
the Lord's Day 1:00 p.m. Eastern we will
have a special guest
this Sunday cos we're back we had to get
the plane New York City Convention thank
you guys for all the support on the
articles and all that stuff and um yeah
we're gonna have six I studio they're
gonna be coming in and they're gonna be
talking about their game that actually
released all platforms now it's called
fail she'll kind of like a Final Fantasy
Tactics from the Chrono Trigger realm
I know your Chrono Trigger guy but if
you're from that genre we're gonna
really talk about his journey in the
industry and now I believe in release
don't switch this week it's on all
platforms theme you know and all the
major console and stuff like that so
they will be in the building and yeah of
course we will talk about the latest
topics in gaming and of course every
Friday I talk at the campfire with my
man Eve artists generally 9:00 a.m.
Eastern but we have special guests like
to ask me adjustment you the pinnacle in
Graham right now
[Laughter]
well yeah every Friday I get to talk the
ninja and the cheetah we come together
at the campfire we talk last word Luda
shoot a podcast mostly destiny focus
right now the other ones but that's what
it is now but again salute this is
fantastic I really appreciate it
he is on you man yeah mine simple you
can find me it's the weird name you can
find it everywhere it's Yvonne test so
EB Ont is twitch Twitter YouTube you'll
find me on all of those if you find the
cheetah you're in the right place so
that's the easy one but yeah seriously
Paul again thank you it's been an honor
and you are welcome anytime so I know
you'll seem you seem to be busy with
podcast lately but if we can I really
suddenly picked up like I don't know
sporadic guests but now I'm kind of a
regular and Rachel surround table I
really don't like to to recent ones so
I'm still getting used to being a
regular on that and yeah I was I've been
on fire to eat and chat like twice the
last between em so I don't know if
that's not had me back to control the
gang old PC that's my go we know you got
your dog to take care of and stuff but
thank you very much
this has been episode 69 of last word
August 16 thank you guys for all tuning
in live on Twitch whether you hear this
on audio platforms that's available on
our YouTube channels where you find it
thank you and go find all of these
awesome people
they are great to follow and listen to
and watch so for all that being said and
this is where we're gonna try and say
this together it has been the last last
word